Cass to designs your cast with your own
x-ray and this Chinese softshell turtle
pees through its mouth Vsauce Kevin here
this is fine
a Dutch design lab has conceptualized
the future highway it features
glow-in-the-dark roads that charge
during the day and light up at night
asphalt paint that changes depending on
the road conditions such as snow flakes
when the roads are icy and lanes that
double as electric car chargers
prototypes for the asphalt paint and
glow-in-the-dark Road are going to be
implemented in 2013 on a stretch of road
in Holland meanwhile in Japan
researchers are trying to make car
interiors appear transparent the system
applies optical camouflage technology
using video from rear cameras to project
onto the backseat and it's all processed
by a computer to make things appear
actual-size currently only the back seat
has been made to look transparent but
the goal is to make the car's interior
completely transparent in order to
eliminate blind spots this is the
earliest known recording of singing from
April 9th 1865 I 8 years
andt sounds kind of scary the exhale fan
is the first truly bladeless ceiling fan
it utilizes the science of laminar flow
between an array of flat disks to
efficiently move air throughout your
environment air is no longer directed
straight down but moves around the room
at 360 degree horizontal flow and passes
over you from the side like a breeze
check out the website for more giant
giraffe sculpture made of flowers for
teenagers created a urine powered
generator presented at Maker Faire
Africa one liter of urine creates up to
six hours of electricity the system
works by first separating out the
hydrogen which goes into a water filter
for purification and gets pushed into
the gas cylinder the gas cylinder pushes
the hydrogen into a cylinder of liquid
borax which is used to remove moisture
from the hydrogen gas finally the
purified hydrogen gas is pushed into the
generator half by half dog and extinct
for nine million years its bearer dog
researchers in Japan are working on ways
to control robots with their minds the
interface uses flashing symbols to
control where the robot moves and how it
interacts with the environment a signal
processing unit on a computer translates
the brain activity and classifies it
into a series of tasks the team can then
instruct the robot on which task to
perform the hope is that this will help
paraplegic people who can't perform
certain tasks on their own MIT game lab
developers created a new game called a
slower speed of light a first-person
prototype game in which the speed of
light slowly decelerates as the user
progresses through the game bringing the
effects of special relativity down to
walking speed with no enemies or real
obstacles the game seems too easy
but with each piece collected by the
player the speed of light slows
incremental players experience the
Doppler effect time dilation the
searchlight effect the runtime effect
and Lorentz transformation all of which
make navigating to the game
exponentially more do
the cult to check it out find the link
below finally true skin is a sci-fi
short film set in the not-too-distant
future in which augmentation is the way
of life our services consist of backing
up those memories or safekeeping if
something were to happen to our physical
self we would simply implant your
memories into renew you that is why it
is crucial to sign up for our daily
backup program so you never lose a
moment of your life I'm gonna leave you
with a 3d simulation of the sun's
magnetic twisters and as always thanks
for watching